a new criminal complaint alleges a
fellow soldier at Fort Hood Texas killed
Vanessa Guillen and hid her body with
the help of his girlfriend Gian
disappeared more than two months ago the
army identified the man as Aaron David
Robinson he killed himself early
Wednesday morning after police stopped
him outside the base cecily aguilar
faces charges after the discovery of
human remains believed to begins the
Army says Aguilar is the estranged wife
of a former Fort Hood soldier
Mireya Villarreal is covering this story
for us Maria good morning what is the
connection or possible connection
between Guillen and Robinson the soldier
who killed himself as authorities closed
in well good morning Tony we now know
that Ian and Robinson were actually
texting each other on the day of her
disappearance that was April 22nd and
these new documents are revealing some
very disturbing details of what
supposedly happened on that day wind
specialist Vanessa Guillen vanished
several agencies including the FBI
descended on Fort Hood to investigate
and now a new criminal complaint alleges
she was murdered the complaint says that
suspects Esley Aguilar's boyfriend
specialist Erin Robinson struck Guillen
in the head with a hammer multiple times
killing her on base before placing her
in a box Robinson then allegedly picked
Aguilar up to help him dispose of geun's
body according to the complaint they
attempted to dismember and burn the body
before burying the remains those people
who suppose he did it did that to my
sister
they're just grace of humanity Jane's
sister Lupe and her family are
distraught wondering how she was put in
danger on Bates words can't describe
everything that
we're feeling right now army
investigators still have not confirmed
if the remains found Tuesday are Vanessa
Gans but their investigation is also
focused on whether she was sexually
harassed before her disappearance
Ian's family says Robinson who died by
suicide Wednesday morning sexually
harassed her and accuses the army of
covering it up they have lights was
multiple times and that's one of the
lies my sister was section in her ass
multiple times the thorough
investigation into sexual harassment
will continue until it's complete in a
press conference yesterday army
investigators said Robinson was not
Indians chain of command and that there
is no credible evidence so far he or
anyone else sexually harassed her how
are we gonna believe their own internal
investigation on themselves the Guillen
family attorney Natalie kawaman says the
Army is hiding something
we believe that he murdered her because
she was going to report the sexual
harassment geon's family says they're
fighting to keep this from happening to
anyone else in the military it's a
disgrace they haven't done nothing at
all to help us that's what we demand a
congressional investigation to be done
the army says that they have ordered an
external investigation of the sexual
harassment program on Fort Hood space
and they've given all the information
they can right now to the Guillen family
as precisely Anyang right now she is
sitting in the Bell County Jail sources
tell us the u.s. marshals will be
picking her up in the next few days
black such a disturbing story more to
come on that Maury I'm sure thank you
very much